today is without question the single
strangest theory I've done in my 6 years
of doing this crazy YouTube thing which
feels appropriate considering it's about
Deadpool so embrace the weird and keep
an open mind because if you do you're in
for one wild ride stick with me now is
it possible that Deadpool is actually
classical American author Ernest
Hemingway anyone still here now that's
impressive
[Music]
hello Internet
welcome to film theory where it's time
for an Easter egg hunt 365 days a year
yeah yeah I know that we just did an
episode on Deadpool which if you haven't
watched yet you should totally watch and
I know that Deadpool 2 doesn't come out
until next year but while I was
researching that last episode I was
reminded of something that initially
triggered my theorists ends back when I
was first watching Logan I forgot about
it at the time because you know I got
kind of distracted by Wolverine taking a
shotgun blast to the chest within like
literally a minute of the movie starting
Volare watching the teaser for the next
Deadpool movie while researching whether
or not Deadpool hit written his own
movies reminded me of it and thus here
we are today so the short itself titled
no good deed is pretty self-explanatory
lots of references are there superhero
tropes obligatory Firefly references a
prolonged shot of a man's naked BOTS but
then you get to the end and a flurry of
small print runs up the screen and out
of sight faster than you can see most
people watching the trailer didn't bat
an eye
Oh random text at the end of a movie
trailer that's weird oh well back to my
normal life in my jumbo popcorn well you
know what some of us don't have normal
lives
the only jumbo popcorn bringing some of
us joy is trying to figure out patterns
and the pop-culture randomness we're
bombarded with every day and then
screaming about it into a microphone
that we keep in our bedroom closet for
15 minutes every week so in an attempt
to fill that jumbo-sized emptiness in my
life I went back and read the text
online only to find that it was a loose
plot summary of Ernest Hemingway's Nobel
prize-winning novella the Old Man and
the sea written in the voice of what
seems to be Deadpool they did a book
report on it but why why is it there for
the lulz for it to just be so crazy and
random I refuse to believe it these
trailers take millions of dollars to
make Marvel and Fox know that these
movie promos get analyzed frame by frame
which is why you have Easter eggs hidden
in literally every corner of the screen
so something like this which might at
first glance seem like a throwaway joke
has gone
to have some sort of deeper meaning but
what well that's the problem I set out
to answer today I searched around for a
bit to see what people thought about
this thing and honestly there weren't
that many online analyses talking about
this moment those few who did wrote it
off as the old man of the sea summary
somehow being connected to the plot of
Logan the movie that everyone was
sitting in the theater about to see now
if you haven't read the book or you've
read it back in high school or didn't
read the book but pretended to have read
it in high school which is I'm guessing
the biggest group here seems like an
appropriate time to fill you in on the
plot the story is about an old fisherman
named Santiago who hasn't caught a fish
for months so long in fact that his
young Protege Madeline is pulled by his
parents to stop fishing with him then
one day the fisherman goes out books a
Marlin so huge he has to tie it to the
outside of his boat but as he sails
towards the shore he starts to attract
sharks the Sharks start to eat the
Marlin and despite Santiago fighting
back the Sharks eat the Marlin to the
point that all that remains is a giant
skeleton this understandably makes
Santiago sad but when the other
fishermen see the giant skeleton of this
enormous fish they realize Santiago
goddess fishing groove back and their
faith in the old man is restored
this makes Santiago happy good work
Ernest Hemingway one of the best works
of American literature right there
ladies and gentlemen man sucks at
fishing goes out catches fish gets eaten
comes back done and this is why I hate
American literature so anyway the online
blogs interpretation was that Santiago
the fisherman is an old weary hero past
his prime just like Logan who has one
final moral victory and wins the
affection of a young student
x-23 or in Logan's case Madeleine I'm
sorry I mean scratch that reverse it
although I gotta say
x-23 hanging out with Santiago would
make the book so much more interesting
but I don't know it just feels off to me
key moments and themes just don't line
up to avoid spoilers let's just say that
the fisherman doesn't end up in the same
place as Logan does at the end of the
old man of the sea so that's a pretty
important detail and there's no fish
parallel in Logan I mean the most
important part of the book is Santiago
battling with the Marlin for days
catching him engaging in this epic
struggle and then watching it slowly get
eaten away over time by the Sharks to me
doesn't match up to anything in Logan
Logan is about the relationship between
Logan and x-23 the old man of the sea is
about the relationship between Santiago
and the fish it's kind of like Moby Dick
DC movies they're always about a guy in
a swish fetish anyway this was truly
meant to be a parallel there'd be more
emphasis on the relationship with man
Olin his protege that would be the x-23
stand and not the fish plus plus why
would a teaser for Deadpool to be
including a bunch of texts about a movie
that we're about to see tix that we
won't be able to read in the theaters so
we have to watch the teaser again at
home after we've already seen the movie
overall it just wasn't the satisfying
answer that I was looking for so my
initial theory and where I started
researching this whole thing was that
maybe the old man of the sea plot is
setting up themes that were gonna see
play out in Deadpool 2 giving us a
little preview of the plot you know I
mean we know that cables gonna be in the
movie and he's kinda old and grouchy so
I searched there as many Deadpool comics
as I could find and none of his
adventures with cable aligned with the
key themes of the old man of the sea
either and if we wanted to get really
literal with it the only time he fights
a big fish is the villain tiger shark
but that's some that's just really
stupid so what is it
why is it there if you peek behind the
scenes at the workings of the show it's
at this point when writing theories that
I start asking myself some really
bizarre questions and I start pursuing
literally any interesting coincidence
that I can find maybe this is a complete
John the dark but maybe out there
somewhere there's a random detail about
Wade Wilson's life that he shares with
Ernest Hemingway and that'll lead to
some other interesting stuff and oh boy
I started researching down that path and
was literally dumbfounded by just how
deep those connections went so deep in
fact that hey I decided to go through
with an entire episode about him so here
we are
maybe the Merc with a mouth was really
the Merc with a pen or typewriter or
whatever Hemingway wrote is garbage on
again not a big fan of Hemingway's
writing submitted for the approval of
the theorist society maybe Deadpool is
Ernest Hemingway oh boy forget fighting
tiger shark
I am full-on jumping the tiger shark for
this one so to answer your first two
questions yes
completely serious and no I have not
recently consumed LSD but I know some of
you are sitting there at home with a
couple of slam dunk rebuttals right off
the bat what about the fact that we know
exactly who Deadpool is ie Wade Wilson
solid point but dig a little deeper and
it starts to get complicated
one of Deadpool's antagonists T ray
claims on many different occasions that
he is the real Wade Wilson and that
Deadpool stole his identity even when
Deadpool was able to poke some holes in
T Ray's story he also admits that he
can't quite be sure who he is as
evidenced by the fact that Deadpool's
memories of his parents ie that they
both died while he was young are
actually quite different from what we
see happen in Deadpool number 34 when he
actually burns his childhood home to the
ground with his parents still inside so
let's just say that Deadpool may not be
the most reliable of narrators of his
own past in fact the whole Deadpool T
ray identity mystery is actually a big
thing that would make a great episode of
comic theory which sadly isn't a thing
that exists yet and probably won't
forever because comics and movies have
so much crossover at this point and
there's so much detail to it that it's
not really worth going into here but
suffice it to say this unreliable memory
coupled with the fact that Deadpool has
died and been resurrected in multiple
times it gets really hard to say exactly
who he is and where he came from so now
that that first rebuttal has one or two
holes in it you might then contend to me
that Ernest Hemingway is about as far
away from the Marvel Universe as you can
get if we don't know the true identity
of who Deadpool really is we can't
assume that this world contains
real-life people like Ernest Hemingway
in its and you're totally right except
that we don't have to assume because
Ernest Hemingway is a canon person in
Marvel Comics and not only that he's
actually connected to dead fools dearest
and bestest friend in the world the guy
who got him his superpowers and the
movie Wolverine
according to the comics Hemingway and
Wolvie hung out during the Spanish Civil
War according to a three-issue arc from
the 1980s does that necessarily prove
that Hemingway is Deadpool no of course
not but does it prove that Hemingway as
a character in the Marvel Universe who
who could have possibly turned into a
superhero over time it apps
lutely opens the door to that sort of
possibility
it's also worth comparing the
personalities of the two as I concluded
in my previous Theory Deadpool enjoys
controlling the narrative of his own
comics games and movie soon to be movies
and tries to paint himself in as
flattering and butt-kicking a light as
possible while Hemingway was mostly
known for writing fiction his
autobiographical work shared the same
desire for that self-promotion one
literary scholar wrote about Hemingway's
memoir a moveable feast said that quote
among the reasons which motivated his
portrayal of self and others were the
desire to get back at people against
whom he held a grudge and the wish to
leave to the world of flattering self
portraits and quotes to put it
differently ie an academic not trying so
hard to look smart Hemingway went out of
his way to make himself look good and
his enemies look bad for example in a
moveable feast there's a passage in
which the famous author f scott
Fitzgerald asks Ernest Hemingway for
help regarding the size of his how do I
put it the size of his not-so-great
Gatsby if you know what I'm saying
an obvious knock to the masculinity of
one of Hemingway's contemporaries and
rivals it's worth noting that Fitzgerald
never disputed this passage but that's
probably because he was already dead 25
years when he got published in his
fiction Hemingway was famous for being
concise but when it came to his own
exploits he was famously willing to
embellish out the wazoo in order to make
himself seem superior to others from a
stylistic standpoint he and Deadpool
practically twinsies and the
similarities aren't just isolated to the
personalities of the two they also
extend to the people around them for
instance one of Deadpool's greatest
allies is cable a cybernetic future
mutant he's fought alongside and has
even merged his DNA with so they're
practically genetically linked family
what if cables plots involves building
an island in the Pacific Ocean out of an
old ship on which he hoped to create a
utopian society called Providence of
course Providence is eventually
destroyed by evil aliens cuz ain't that
always the way with utopian societies
but in a truly bizarre twist of fate
Ernest Hemingway's brother his brother
so again a partner in life who is
connected through DNA did almost the
exact
same thing Lester Hemingway decided to
create his own island nation in the
1960s which he did by stringing together
large rafts and weighing them down with
an engine block only a few miles off the
coast of Jamaica he actually did this
and while this might sound like the plan
of someone whose wardrobe consists
mostly of aluminum foil he was generally
an organized operation the island which
he called New Atlantis had a flag it
issued postage it even wrote a
constitution before it was destroyed by
storms just a few years years after its
creation granted this is a direct proof
that Deadpool and Hemingway are
connected just because they share a guy
who they're also genetically related to
in some capacity who decided to do this
random island experiment but what are
the freaking odds of that one how many
comic book arcs are there of manmade
islands how many instances of manmade
islands are there in real life and how
many of those two instances are crossing
over in each other's movie trailers but
the comparisons between Deadpool and
Hemingway start to get really
interesting when you start to look at
their biographical similarities for one
they were both skilled military types
Deadpool was originally a member of the
US Army Special Forces but as someone
unwilling to follow orders and protocol
he found much more success in his
paramilitary mercenary work for which we
all know and love and Hemingway also
wanted to be a part of the military
attempting to enlist to fight in World
War one but they turned him away because
of his poor eyesight he still had a
desire for combat though so Hemingway
ended up as an ambulance driver in World
War one and in the early stages of World
War two when Hemingway was living in
Cuba he convinced the Cuban government
to let him outfit his fishing boat with
machine guns and hand grenades so that
he could attack any German u-boats that
he spotted fishing boat bad ass this guy
was crazy we also know that both a
Deadpool and heavy we're dangerous and
hanhan combat in cable and Deadpool
number 36 deadpool manages to defeat
another mercenary named taskmaster
mano-a-mano with his hands chained
together
similarly Hemingway was notorious as a
brawler anyway boxing champion of the
world in the 1920s Jack Dempsey was once
quoted as saying but there was one
fellow I wouldn't mix it up with that
was Ernest Hemingway I had this sense
that Hemingway who really thought he
could box would come out of the corner
like a madman
so Dempsey's full comments make it clear
that he didn't think Hemingway would
have won necessarily but if you're an
amateur boxer and the heavyweight
champion of the world doesn't want to
fight you cuz he thinks you're crazy
well it must be pretty damn crazy the
details here are obviously different but
the personality and abilities share a
lot of similarities we've got two people
who crave combat but prefer to do it
under their own terms and aren't afraid
to mix it up in a crazy off-the-wall
style if the need arises but I'm sure a
lot of you probably still aren't
satisfied and I don't blame you contrary
to what many of you commenters think I
actually do have some level of
self-awareness and I tend to know when
I've made a good theory versus a bad one
or actually probably more accurately one
that I'm convinced of versus one that
I'm like there's still a lot of holes in
this thing surprise surprise just
because I do an episode on something
doesn't necessarily mean I believe it
myself I just try to make as strong a
case as possible and if I think I've
done a decent job of it yeah it becomes
a full-length episode and sure Hemingway
and Deadpool have some similar
personality traits some similarities and
temperament and physical prowess were
canonically present in the comments and
yeah even share some crazy similarities
and actions of people who are
genetically linked to them but there's
still a pretty big problem here all of
this is still coincidental the details
just don't lock perfectly together you
know they're similar but they're not
exact well except for that island thing
that was weirdly specific like that is
about as precise as you can possibly get
so yeah that and the fact that Hemingway
chilled with Wolverine that was a weird
one too but for this theory to really
have a shot at even being remotely
plausible I need to prove that Hemingway
could have had a superpower it's like
say Deadpool signature healing factor
dramatic pause you know what I'm about
to do right
put doubts in your head about one of
America's most famous authors having
super healing is it enough to call him a
superhero though you tell me over the
course of his life Ernest Hemingway
demonstrated that he was practically
invulnerable to disease by contracting
malaria hepatitis pneumonia dysentery
skin cancer and anthrax yeah anthrax the
terrorists poised
none of which managed to kill him and
let's remember this was all three 1960
when the advice you got from most
doctors was to smoke cigarettes to calm
your nerves and make sure that you got
your daily dose of bacon fats but no I'm
not done yet
he was also struck by mortar fire while
driving that ambulance his back in World
War one he once shot himself in the leg
while hunting sharks presumably trying
to set the Guinness World Record for
manliest afternoon in history he
survived a plane crash deep in the heart
of Africa away from most medical
authorities and when he boarded another
plane the next day it exploded before
takeoff leaving Hemingway with a severe
concussion a ruptured kidney and liver
damage to airplane disasters in two days
that is some final destination nonsense
and yet he still survived later well on
a fishing expedition he was caught in a
brush fire and sustained second-degree
burns to most of his body he recovered
from every single one of those injuries
and catastrophes so today's episode
which started as an unbelievable stretch
boils down to this Ernest Hemingway
real-life American author who just so
happened to be an unbreakable glutton
for punishment canonically meets up with
Deadpool's nemesis Wolverine and source
of his powers in a number of comic books
shares personality and physical
similarities with Deadpool had a
genetically linked brother who created
an island out of a ship just like
Deadpool's genetically linked to a like
Abel does and Deadpool just so happens
to reference him for literally no reason
in the teaser for his upcoming movie
sometimes too many coincidences point to
no coincidence at all but hey that's
just a theory
a film theory and cuts Hemingway am i
right
manliest badass in history seriously I
hate the guys writing but he has got an
incredible life story you know what else
made him the pillar of testosterone that
he was that beard of his dude had some
amazing facial hair but how do you shave
a beard that manly what razors could
possibly conquer Hemingway's follicular
fortitude three words dollar shave club
the
manliest of men deserve the manliest of
razors and even if you're not a manly
man like me you can appreciate the
razors - just saying everybody's got to
shave even the manliest of women or just
the women of women in general so
wherever you are on that spectrum you
can give yourself a shave worthy of
Hemingway himself by following this
special link given to only us theorists
you see it on screen right now it's
dollarshaveclub.com slash film theory
there's also that link in the
description follow that link and Dollar
Shave Club will give you the princely
treatment for the popper price for just
a limited time you guys can get your
first month of the executive razor with
a tube of they're shaving butter with
free shipping and for refills after that
your razors are just a few bucks a month
like buttah theorists but uh even if it
was a crappy shave it'd be worth the
price but you know what it's something
that you can't really understand until
you try it yourself feel the razor in
your hand and I guarantee you'll be glad
you did if you're not you can cancel it
any time plus the process doesn't even
require you to leave your couches but
groove first your order Dollar Shave
Club online and boom it's delivered
right to your door or manly fishing dock
it's just fast and easy which is
important when you're a man with a shark
you got a harpoon honestly Dollar Shave
Club is just the smarter choice fast
great quality and a great price it's why
I made the switch from my electric razor
what you think this baby-smooth face is
because I can't grow facial hair ha I'm
like a werewolf every morning but Dollar
Shave Club keeps my hairy just a little
less scary so treat yourself you deserve
it experience the best shave you've ever
had for only $5 smash that link in the
description or go to our special URL
dollarshaveclub.com slash film theory
just try it you'll be glad that you did
now that if you'll excuse me there's a
super villain I've been looking to
tackle for quite some time I'll see you
all next week
click the link